[Musique]
ça si on rame passe comme ça la main de
la voiture je suis pas tout à fait sûr
mais pour le reste quasiment plus forts
[Musique]
d'un soutien au brut s'est pas enfiler
les gens pendant huit ans j'ai vécu avec
un sale type
un sale mais qu'un minable tu sais quoi
le pierre il a bien dit innocent en
prison
je suis si heureuse d'avoir une bonne ça
va il a bien le gain la feda muscles il
a pris les cinq ans louis c'est notre
faute tout ça il perd du soutif idée
complètement largués c'est quoi ce truc
de massacrer calmement les gens comme ça
on n'avait pas vraiment eu de battue on
avait l'impression que tu as rangé ton
bureau ça monsieur
pardon bolton parfaitement même s'ils
savent ce que j'ai fait 80 ans je suis
innocent j'ai droit de scalper des
visuels son trottoir
non mais tu te rends compte fait le rac
de semaine chez les deux conceptions du
peloton parce que désolé je suis encore
travail
je vais prendre mon but est de connaître
s'il vous plaît avec le pain demandé de
régler quitté l'établissement je peux
retourner un peu plus souple ça où ils
ont failli un peu tard pardonnez moi
mais je voulais pas laisser les cuisines
ouvertes deux heures de retard
[Musique]
bien sûr que je n'ai pas marre de voir
deux mois franchi